Few DC Comics fans could have predicted a
few years ago that Warner Bros. would release
a new Batman movie in 2022 that is not only
set outside of the DC Extended Universe but
also stars someone other than Ben Affleck
as the Caped Crusader.
However, that's exactly what has happened.
Now, after entrusting "War for the Planet
of the Apes" director Matt Reeves with its
most coveted superhero property, WB has finally
unveiled the Robert Pattinson-led "The Batman"
for everyone to see.
Taking inspiration from multiple different
comic book and cinematic sources, "The Batman"
isn't like a lot of the other comic book movies
that have come before it.
While the film adopts the same kind of grounded,
gritty aesthetic that dominated Christopher
Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy, "The Batman"
goes even further with that style.
The movie also leans harder into the detective
side of its titular character, delivering
a movie that is not only a superhero flick
but also a thrilling and genuinely intriguing
crime mystery.
Thanks to the presence of its primary villain,
Edward Nashton AKA The Riddler, "The Batman"
also gets incredibly dark at certain points.
As a matter of fact, it may very well be the
darkest live-action Batman movie that comic
book fans have ever seen.
Batfans beware, spoilers ahead!
From its opening scene, "The Batman" sets
Paul Dano's Riddler up to be the scariest
live-action villain in Batman movie history.
Opening with one long, voyeuristic shot from
the character's POV, the film's first sequence
sees The Riddler break into the home of Gotham
City's mayor on Halloween night and brutally
kill the man while his family members are
out trick-or-treating.
The sequence is unexpectedly dark and creepy,
but it's only the first of the film's many
impactful and unsettling Riddler scenes.
Indeed, over the course of its nearly 3-hour
runtime, "The Batman" follows The Riddler
as he goes on a bloody and gruesome crusade,
killing many of Gotham City's most powerful
and corrupt law enforcement officials.
With each of his kills, The Riddler reveals
a little bit more about himself and the relationship
that he thinks he has with Pattinson's Batman.
However, his main mission in "The Batman"
is to expose the corruption that has run rampant
throughout Gotham for decades by killing the
people who allowed the city's citizens to
be taken advantage of, lied to, and kept in
the dark.
As a result, the character, who was partially
inspired by terrifying real-life figures like
the Zodiac Killer, sets out to send a different
message with each of the crimes scenes he
leaves behind.
With that in mind, it's worth asking: Which
character in "The Batman" experiences the
most gruesome death?
Due to the nature of his mission in "The Batman,"
The Riddler leaves a surprisingly high number
of victims in his wake.
Indeed, the villain performs several heinous
acts throughout the movie, including strapping
a bomb to the neck of Gil Colson, Gotham City's
corrupt district attorney, at one point in
its second act.
That said, the most gruesome death in "The
Batman" is actually the one that fans see
the least of in the film itself, and that's
the murder of corrupt police commissioner
Pete Savage.
Introduced near the tail end of the film's
first crime scene sequence, Savage is initially
set up to be a major thorn in the sides of
both James Gordon and Batman.
However, Savage's presence in "The Batman"
comes to a quick and unexpected end early
on in the film when he is revealed to be the
second of The Riddler's victims.
Unlike most of the deaths in "The Batman,"
Savage's demise isn't shown on-screen when
it happens.
Instead, the character's death is revealed
in a news report, which briefly shows a video
that The Riddler recorded during Savage's
last moments.
In it, the audience briefly sees Savage sitting
with a complex trap strapped across his chest
and face.
Later in the film, it is revealed that The
Riddler injected Savage with rat poison and
then placed rats in the trap on his body,
which eventually chewed and burrowed into
his face and neck.
The complex, depraved, and drawn-out nature
of Savage's death is what makes it truly horrifying
to think about, and that's also why "The Batman"
ultimately shows very little of it and only
briefly alludes to the state of Savage's body
after he is discovered by his police colleagues.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
DC movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.